Thanks oh it's Nicole and I okay so
thanks for everyone for coming today
people may come in but I want to make
sure Raja has enough time because this
is a proposal defense
for his master's thesis raja cholan as
you may know is works on my care
management plus team but is also masters
of science and clinical informatics
students and actually has been recently
awarded a scholarship which I'm sure
he'll thank the institution for he's
been working on clinical quality
measures really delving deep into how
they work now for many of the large
health reform efforts across the United
States and then what they're gonna look
like for the future so it's an
incredibly important topic for many
people who are trying to implement these
and we're very proud so i defending this
proposal today so there'll be general
public time and then we'll get together
afterwards privately so I know there's a
fellow's meeting just after that was
just need a few minutes all right thanks
hey I think this is on all right thank
you Dave
so like Dave said I've worked a lot with
quality measures and one thing he he
said is that I've I dug deep or delves
deep and that's actually a good segue
for the beginning of my talk because I'm
gonna spend quite a bit of time on the
background and explain to you some of
the issues so clinical quality language
is a new specification released by hl7
for representing the logic for clinical
quality measures and clinical decision
support however I'm going to be focusing
on the cqms and so I'll start with the
definition so right now in healthcare
and informatics there's a goal to
increase population health and one way
of measuring that is with these tools
called electronic clinical quality
measures their intent identify care gaps
and they're based on evidence base
guidelines and they are calculated using
data elements found in EHRs that look at
different processes structures and
outcomes and they're becoming a
fundamental part of payment with the
quality payment program and MIPS which
is the merit based incentive payment
system where clinics and hospitals have
to submit quality data and right now
they just have to submit to be eligible
but moving forward they'll be
benchmarked against other clinics and
based on the performance they'll receive
reimbursement adjustments accordingly so
as any there's different parts of a cqm
here's it I won't spend too much time on
this example because I'm gonna dive
deeper into another example but you
might have your denominator or you
always have a denominator which is the
subset of patients for whom the measure
is designed to address and then you have
your numerator which is the subset of
the denominator where some type of
clinical action is supposed to happen
whether that's a medication or or like
you actually are looking at some type of
measurement like their blood pressure
measurement for example in their record
and some measures have exclusions where
there are patients where it's
inappropriate for them to receive some
evidence-based guidelines so you exclude
them from the calculation and you avoid
harms for those patients and so to get
the so these are the parts of this eqm
and they have a special document there
that CMS releases in the used to be in
the ECM library it's now called the ec
qi resource center you can access these
as HTML documents it's called the health
quality measure format for the h qmf and
here's a screenshot it's this grey table
I'm also going to pull one up and walk
you through it and these are updated
regularly and so as you scroll through
this grey table you'll see there's a
human readable definition like the
narrative description there's some
information about the clinical rationale
behind the measure who developed the
measure and then they also include this
pseudocode which is intended to help you
walk through the logic so
it helps breakdown the initial
population and the denominator what
diagnoses are included the types of
encounters that are specified and then
how you're supposed to exclude the
patients and whatnot and so now I'm
gonna show you an example of this so
this is for tobacco use screening and
cessation this is actually a version 6.1
I'm not sure how this actually aligns
with the current version but this is for
like the 2018 measurement year and so
you can see in this text description
here it's I'll just read it to you
percentage of patients aged 18 years and
older who were screened for tobacco use
one or more times within 24 months and
which is in caps lock which is actually
important who received tobacco cessation
intervention if identified as a tobacco
user so the first thing you have to do
is like squint and look at this and to
turn like figure out what this actually
means what is this actually trying to
measure and so the part like the reason
I highlighted the and is the first part
of it is looking at screening for adult
patients in the last two years did you
ask them about their tobacco use status
and then the second part is if they are
a tobacco user were they given cessation
intervention or a medication and then
they actually want you to break this
down into three different rates one is
just the screening rate B is of the
smokers who receive cessation and then C
is the composite measure where you have
to basically include your entire
population as the denominator and then
calculate your numerator the right way
and so as you scroll through this h2 map
like I said there's some of the the
disclaimer and the clinical rationale
and then they help you they sort of try
to simplify the denominator in numerator
which is what I sort of tried to walk
you through just now and then you
finally get to the pseudocode and so
here when you look in the pseudocode
what's important is that for the first
population the rate one that they want
you to report they tell you to include
tobacco non-users and
users which makes sense because that one
was looking at just the screening for
population two it tells you to only look
at tobacco users and then for the third
one again it tells you to use both
because this is the composite measure
and so then the next step is once you
look at this if you were to actually
implement this so Dave door has a tool
called the integrated care coordination
information system and so we eat CL the
data out of extract transform and load
the data out of the epic clarity tables
into this my sequel database so here's
just a snippet of the sequel code which
I actually wrote for this smoking
cessation measure it's a slightly older
version but you can see that translating
it from the pseudo code or the narrative
description into code we actually had
the the smoking screening comes in as a
text from the social history tab into
this table and our my sequel database so
we actually have to do some text
processing and sequel it's challenging
and the implementation of this measure
was was pretty tough and and we were
lucky actually for screening they were
like it was semi structured they were
these are I guess smart phrases or
something so there were only six
possible options for the text and so we
were able to break it down but when you
look at the cessation text it was not
structured at that time maybe they've
updated it so there was all types of
variation in that field so the reason I
showed you all of this was to prove to
you that implementing cqms can be hard
as you just saw with that example and I
worked on this grant called the evidence
now grant initiative funded by the
agency for Healthcare Research and
quality on Dave's team we worked with
about a hundred clinics in Oregon and
tried to extract measures out of their
EHRs and there were different ways that
the clinics generated their data either
directly from the EHR vendor reports
they might have connected to another H
IT system or they had data teams that
wrote their own measures and so we knew
that there was this variation and we I
attribute some of that variation to that
process of looking at the measure
specifications and then translating it
into code and finding the right
data and so about a year ago one of our
measures updated and we knew that and we
were collecting these measures quarterly
and we knew that in the first quarter
about three fourths of the clinics were
submitting old version and some were
submitting the new version and so I was
very interested in this variation and so
because of this variation hl7 to assist
has come up with the new pseudo-code
framework so I showed you an example in
that smoking cessation measure for the
different populations they're going to
replace that with this new standard
called clinical quality language which
is a new set of code framework it's
supposed to more precisely represent
natural language and reduce the burden
this is a direct quote from the CGI
resources Resource Center reduce the
burden on implementers for consuming
these measure artifacts and I'll show
you an example now so this is a little
hard to read this is a new measure it's
not the smoking cessation measure
anymore this is appropriate treatment
for children with upper respiratory
infection so this is the traditional
pseudo code the current version and this
is clinical quality language so in the
current version what they do is so they
tell you here that you need to have a
diagnosis of upper respiratory infection
and then within that they tell you all
the different types of encounters that
the patient should have and then as you
come down here it tells you the
numerator criteria and actually tells
you the denominator exclusions before
telling you the numerator criteria which
is whether or not the patient was
received an antibiotic within three days
of the diagnosis and this is for kids
who were aged three to eight three
months to 18 years that's specified up
here and then they tell you all the
value such which are this the codes and
terms to define these clinical concepts
and now this is the new version cql
defines the value sets first which I
think might be good because now when
they refer those concepts later in the
pseudo code
you kind of already know what they are
they had they also defined the
measurement period here 3 to 18 3 months
to 18 years right away
they define the encounters and the
diagnosis separately which i think is
helpful in the first version diagnosis
and encounter was all sort of jumped was
all lumped together up here and then
they actually tell you the numerator
criteria first exclusions aren't
included here it might might just be
this example or they might I don't know
why there probably would be a line for
exclusions and then that what I think is
interesting is down here they actually
tell you how to compute the measure
which is pretty simple it's numerator
divided by denominator times 100 but
that's actually explicitly defined in
cql so how is CQ I'll intended to be
used I'm gonna this is the vision from
the from CMS so currently this is the
current process which I sort of walked
you through you have the H qmf and then
there's this process of translating that
from the measure specifications into an
implementation and right now a lot of
that translation is manual there are
some there is a machine readable
specification as well in XML and there
are some systems that can translate that
directly into code but most healthcare
organizations do require some type of
manual translation right now which is
what we learned in that evidence now
grant and so what cql is intended to do
eventually is to have this translator
and so you can go directly from that
pseudocode into a script sequel script
or something that you can implement on
against your clinical data directly but
this is not a trivial lift this
automated translator I don't even think
I don't know if it's even been
implemented successfully to prove that
it works maybe a couple academic
institutions or something but it has not
been widely implemented yet and so this
is the aspirational view is that your
CQL
could be translated directly against
different institutions healthcare data
but like I said this isn't a trivial
list so probably for the next three to
five years they're still going to be a
lot of this manual translating happening
and so that's why for my problem what
the purpose of this project is to
specifically dive into cql and find that
and try to assess the benefits and
challenges there's not a whole lot of
literature about cql most of the stuff
is hl7 draft documentation there are
github libraries with example measure
definitions and there's a lot of stuff
about the translator you can download
some translator services to try to get
your automated scripting but so what I
want to do in short is a qualitative
assessment to understand the benefits
and challenges from semi-structured
interviews with experts and the
hypothesis is that CTO will be perceived
to be better in terms of learnability or
the interpretation of the logic of these
measures so the methods are pretty
straightforward I guess in one sentence
I've already said it is to assess the
benefits and challenges of CQL and so
I'll specifically go into each of these
different components of my methods now
so the first thing I have to do it's I
guess it's more of a task is prioritized
measures to choose so like the upper
respiratory infection I showed you the
example of the old version or the
current version of the pseudo code in
the HTML format and the new cql format I
need to specify specifically if choose
measures to show during these interviews
so these are four that I've chosen that
I've narrowed it down to and four might
be too much to show in like an hour
interview with an expert so I need to
prioritize which may be - I'll use and
then I also need to I need to think
through the order of which I that I'm
going to present these to the experts
showing them the old version first
versus cql first so I'll touch on that a
little bit more later and so part of the
reason I chose these measures is that
they cover
a variety of different clinical concepts
and they vary in complexity so in the HQ
MF that tells you the different value
sets and quality data model elements so
we I just counted those as a proxy to to
show you the complexity of these
measures so the first measure is a heart
failure measure it has 26 of these qdm
elements it includes meds and lab tests
and encounters and diagnoses and then
some of the other measures only look at
meds and encounters and diagnoses and
they have fewer elements and if you
actually look just looking at the cql
it's a lot shorter and so I think it's
important to show one may be more
complex than that if I choose two
measures one more complex measure and
one less complicated measure okay the
next thing I have to do is identify and
recruit experts so there are the hl7
there's a clinical quality information
working group they meet every week and
then there's the group that developed
the draft measures for cql as well as
the measure authoring tools one of those
places where they can do some of this
automatic translation of the machine
readable see QM definition so I could
reach out to these people to get some
technically trained people and in
quality measures that know about
implementation and know about these
specifications but I think it's also
going to be important to recruit people
who are clinically trained who may not
know as much about cql specifically but
they still have to go through that
process of reading them measures of
specifications and being able to
articulate it for like the quality
improvement role and see if they're
interpret the new model next I have to
develop the interview guide so this is
an outline of the types of things that
I'll collect so for every expert I'll
collect information about their
background and role of career and try to
assess their level of familiarity with
quality measures HQ mfcq l and just
programming in general and then when I
show them the versions of the measures
really what I'm interested
understanding is what's confusing about
looking at cql what's understandable
what's ambiguous and then yeah collect
all of that from the interviews a really
important step as a part of this is
piloting the interviews so as I'm
scheduling this and this will happen
soon I have a timeline slide coming up
I'll pilot the interviews with two or
three people so that I can get feedback
figure out what what might be awkward or
what can be improved should I send stuff
to them ahead of time
so I actually have a couple people in
mind already for whom I can pilot with
so I'll briefly touch on to some
frameworks so this was a framework I
used four by a baingan SMED about
algorithms in house and pseudocode and
how they're supposed to work there's a
lot of text on the slide but basically
he breaks down how an algorithm has
these sub structures and their relations
and they should be explained in an
actual language and so as I walk you
through cql you know there were the
different sub structures and they and
they were showing the relationship
between the different clinical concepts
and so I sort of used I'm going to use
this to help inform some of the
questions I asked specifically about cql
and the current HTML app format and then
these I took from a reading actually
from BMI 560 come one come Lenski
framework for evaluation
so for accountability I'm going to
really focus on confidence and
satisfaction with interviewers accuracy
I'm not going to do any type of
quantitative measure of that I think I'm
just going to try to heuristic ly
determine if if the people are right or
not for the cqm logic and have them talk
me through it as well and then
specifically which will be helpful for
the cql community and the EC qi resource
center is highlighting any challenges i
actually talked to a guy that like and
he basically invented CQ oh he told me
to be really helpful to get the gotchas
so that they could iterate and improve
it and strengthen the development of CQ
oh
and then yeah valuation foreknowledge so
within the measure criteria as I showed
you in that example there were temporal
considerations so you have to look at
the measurement period as well as the
age of the people and for some of the
criteria like certain clinical actions
have to happen in a certain time like
for the screening for tobacco use it had
to be in the last two years so stuff
like that if there's specific elements
that are either temporal or related to
the clinical concepts or the way that
they outlined the diagnosis to include
I'm going to specifically try to ask
about those so I'll do the interviews
and I will transcribe all of those I'm
going to use an immersion
crystallization approach to analyze it
and so to do this I'll transcribe all
the interviews and we'll come up with
the codebook to label the text with my
committee and we'll have a
standardization process around this and
how to use them specifically we're going
to be looking at the benefits challenges
learnability
ambiguity confidence satisfaction in
just thought level as they look at cql
and then we'll independently code the
data and iteratively come back together
to compare and reach consensus and then
I'll probably use Atlas Ti as my
software for this a one thing I forgot
to mention in the recruitment stage is
I'm aim to recruit 10 to 20 experts
because that's where saturation is
usually reached in this type of
qualitative analysis and then as we do
this we'll analyze the findings and
group the things into concepts and
themes so I don't know how well you can
see this I'm hoping to start in spring
term start recruiting experts and doing
the interviews in May hopefully get all
the interviews done by early June and
and move on into the analysis phase by
then which I think is doable to do 10 to
20 interviews in a month especially
since I know some of these people I'm
not reaching out to strangers
and yeah with that I think I'm down I'm
open for questions hey that's a great
work that's I've done some some more or
less implementation of studies in areas
that are out there they're tremendously
difficult to interpret and and I can see
that definitely it's it's an issue
across the board my comment was
basically you know there are a lot of
people are Hsu here implementing and
doing these kind of quality measures and
and do you intend to really include
those and like like Adam stone for
example chief of our reporting services
you can tend to include those people as
well yeah I will I actually have it
formally listed all the people are
intended to include like the potential
pool I guess it's kind of like a quality
measure it's like my initial population
and then who's gonna end up being in my
denominator but I absolutely would like
to include people from OHSU
especially cuz I could probably meet
with them face-to-face where I could
learn more just from from that rather
than all these virtual calls off to set
up but I'm definitely to leverage Dave's
network so which he know that I'm stones
and those people really well and if you
have other suggestions I'll take those
or if you want to participate as well
right so initially I had all these
aspirations to show like sorry I had all
these aspirations dummy patient level
data and then see if they could look at
the cql versus the current HQ math model
and identify the right patients who
should be passing and failing measures
and I thought about using like Likert
scales for the confidence and
satisfaction and it ultimately came down
to scope issue because this is just a
master's thesis but also I think the
nature of the research question is more
a qualitative a qualitative approach
might be better because I'm really
trying to go after the the challenge is
the stuff that's ambiguous and so I
wasn't really focusing so much on
accuracy it's really about satisfaction
and confidence the accuracy was more of
just something that I was trying to get
out from there like Gestalt level or
their their ability to interpret from
the cql what the measure is intending so
just thinking forward in terms of
adoption right so if really what you're
interested in you're like overall
question is are people going to adopt
this language is that maybe why you're
more interested in satisfaction and
confidence because regardless of how
good people might be at it they don't
like it they're not going to use it
exactly yeah and it's brand-new
actually are going to release cql
officially I think this fall so exactly
right let's see how good it is and then
I guess people don't have a choice about
what they have what they're going to use
because they have to rely on whatever
CMS puts out for the specification
thanks for the presentation I can't wait
to hear your result I wanted that I
think you answered the question you're
going to do some of these interviews
virtually in some in person or will they
all be virtual problem majority virtual
just because the hl7 working group those
people are all all over the country I'll
probably use or I use zoom currently on
some other projects that works pretty
well and then will people have
familiarity with the new format or will
you like I'm just wondering how much of
your time you might have to spend
explaining to them before you get
because it sounds aggressive to do go
through two measures with them in an
hour on their own although I agree would
be awesome to do more than one yeah
that's a good question like I've
actually I'm in the recruitment phase
the identification of experts like I'm
not actually sure if it's a good idea to
include people that are too familiar
with cql because they're gonna be biased
there probably is going to say secure
better or they'll want want it to be
better
or they'll actually think it's better
because they helped develop it in some
way so that's exactly why I'm doing the
pilot I think and I'll pick people at
different levels I don't know maybe the
you know I didn't talk for too long here
I could probably abbreviate a lot of the
intro of this potox
but even I think like if I spent five to
ten minutes doing like a similar intro
to what I did in this talk it might be
enough and if it's not if I learn the
pilot side if not I could send out
pretty work or some type of link to the
ecq I Center to get people up to speed
but I agree with you that's why I
originally wanted to show all four of
those measures but I don't think that's
how possible in an hour
I have two questions one is so what bye
why does this matter
do you have any evidence that these
implementations that there's some kind
of problem with them that's a leading
question I know the answer but you guys
don't and the second is it gets that
learnability so you know are you
actually assessing learning ability in
the way that you're describing this and
how are you gonna accommodate that
people probably know HTML and not cql in
that concept okay so the first question
as you know since we've studied this
with working with these clinics is that
there there are problems there and we've
studied the variation in these met
implementations of these measures so
specifically without date process we
looked at that like some people will be
submitting old versions versus new
versions of the measures and a lot of
times these change they change the
patients weren't included and that can
result in differences in performance
also when I go out to clinics a lot of
times they don't have back-end access to
their data and so they use some type of
friend UI query builder like similar to
reporting workbench to try to estimate
the logic and so they sometimes will
shortcut the actual measure
specifications is to try to get
something close and I think they end up
reporting that stuff to CMS a lot of
times as well and so I think that's part
of these and why I'm interested in this
and the so what is ideally we want
standard representations of these
measures so that we can compare the
performance across sites and then tie
them to payment because right now I
don't know how they're it's tough to do
that because we have
the data and we've looked at the
variation and it's bad clinics also well
I know that what we did this analysis
for different look-back period like some
clinics and report the full 12-month
look-back period and some can only do
either a quarter thirty days or a
quarter 90-day lickers 6-month look-back
periods and I don't remember the exact
numbers but I know that there was a lot
more variation in the non-standard
look-back period versus the clinics that
could submit the one year look-back
period so that's evidence that having a
standard closer to standard
representation might be better so your
performance is a better bell curve so
for your second question about
learnability yeah that's a good I
actually don't really know I guess
that's part of the process I'll learn do
the pilots actually something I'm
concerned about as a risk for my methods
is the or that's why I mentioned like
the order that I have to show the
measures so there's I thought about this
like I could do a random I can randomize
it somehow so that for one interview I
would show the cql first and also the
word of the measures could be random as
well I could show a complex measure
would seek you off first and for the
other person maybe it would end up being
a simple measure with the H QMF version
first so I think that's how I could try
to address that mitigate that risk and
then also I'll be collecting the salt
their self-reported expertise in these
areas so I can try to analyze the data
that way by expertise level